[Musique]
on a tenu de cette estivale histoire de
montrer qu il y avait pas mal appris les
jeunes sont à la tulle et de montrer
aussi le savoir-faire de nos couturiers
au monde entier
[Musique]
c'est le plein de joie parce que
être jeune étudiant et pouvoir
participer à un défilé international
c'est d'une manière générale c'est pas
donné à n'importe qui puisque nous
sommes d'être congolais nous avons
utilisé du nasria et a plus que la
fiente sa voiture si intense palatini
venue la mode africaine c'est une salle
c'est du savoy fait c'est de la
créativité ca de l'originalité au feq
car c'est le vélo aeternam on
touche aux élevages éléments
professionnels de la réalité
[Musique]
savoir faire une robe ce n'est pas un
créateur de mode ces formations pour moi
c'est essentiel et devrait être
échelonné que je m'en coûte 1 euro
au terme de mon essayages je pense qu'il
faut encore il ne serait ce qu'une
formation mannequin ça montre aussi la
formation mannequin dire aux mannequins
qu'est ce qui devrait partir comment ils
doivent venir commun doivent se
présenter et comment ils doivent
réagir avec le créateur avec lequel ils
essayent voilà donc je pense qu'il faut
encore plus de modules de formation et à
tous les niveaux de métier
[Musique]